so much relief on behalf of the
relatives I've got Charlotte Hennessy
here whose dad Jimmy died at
Hillsborough tell me about your your
memories what happened to your dad
m-my parents are the match with him one
of his friends and James Delaney here
also very sadly lost his life he exited
out of the pen him possibly pulled out
you know by in police offices well
initially went through the turnstiles
with his ticket where he should have
been straight down the tunnel where he
should have been into pen three and
unfortunately I don't know much after
that other than he was found moving and
alive on the pitch and I'd heard today
you know my dad has a different cause of
death to everybody else because he
wasn't dead he was unconscious for a
very long time and should still be here
now with me today
I shouldn't be standing here giving this
interview and I shouldn't be listening
to these inquests what happened there
he's the medical attention that he so
desperately required he just didn't get
it he wasn't given you know what he was
he had a right to life he had a right to
medical attention a right to health you
know and you know he was given some help
obviously you know police officer tried
to save his life but fact is it's been
proven today that there were massive
failings
and those failings are what caused my
dad's death and those failings started
as you said on it the language of you
shall is important with a ticket as he
should have had went where he should
have gone yeah and these were the
failings this is part of the cover-up
these art of the the explanations the
excuses that have been made throughout
yeah you all right your life right he
likes a child isn't another yeah you
know my dad's always been an innocent
victim as have every other Liverpool
Firm which has been proved today you
know they were not responsible for the
cause of the disaster they did not
contribute to the cause of the disaster
and now the whole world knows that those
failing started with David duckenfield
and we need to move away from this you
know incompetent much commander we've
had to listen to that for two years that
these were the actions of an incumbent
and match commander but he didn't take
any advice
he changed operational orders you know
he did things his way and now it's been
proven through a very have decided jury
it was a gross negligent therefore and
therefore unlawful of Killington but
just tell me shot as you sat there and
you heard that I mean of course you you
knew that was the case you've you've
known that for all your life but you've
you've never heard it you've never heard
that that underlying what did it mean to
you what did it mean to other families
and what was your reaction obviously you
know this is a huge relief for us now
and what to hear it out loud was such a
shock and I think I'm still in shock now
I think it's going to take a while to
process that you know it's unlawful
killing and it's just I don't know how
I'm just completely shocked what's it
like I mean you've been nervous about
that because you heard we all heard
didn't hey and you don't know any more
more than us of course you know these
proceedings are tightly controlled quite
rightly we heard that the jury couldn't
decide they originally wanted on this
very question was question six on the
list they originally wanted the coroner
said I want a unanimous decision on this
and on all the ones they came back said
we can't we can't all agree he said well
okay I will accept it if it's seven two
they then said yes we have decided but
we didn't know which way you didn't know
last night you were waiting to come in
what you would hear yeah I think that
was the biggest fear that it was a
majority in the unknown against unlawful
killing and but then you know we've been
wronged for so many years you don't know
what to expect and so I was so anxious
this morning I've never ever experienced
anxiety like it and you know and then
when when they answered yes to unlawful
killing I don't even really remember it
to be honest it's just all a bit of a
blur now
and yeah you know we did it and then
what flowed from that has we've been
been discussing also taken into careful
consideration here is that issue a
responsibility there's only one way that
the finger is pointing is when we we
need to explore that more as a society
but no responsibility for innocent
football fans caring too much to enjoy
themselves that's all and you know we've
always known that Liverpool fans went to
blame and now the world knows it too and
all the slander and all the lies they
stand for nothing anymore - they don't
they you know the proof and the truth is
out there
just tell us lastly I mean what's life
been like for you growing up your father
taken away for you in such a cruel
fashion you see our woman are we yeah
the kids yeah I was I was six years old
now 33 with children of my own and you
know as an effect on them as well I've
had to explain to them why I'm needing
to come here what happened to my my dad
their granddad who they're never going
to know you know but in life growing up
in the shadow of Hillsborough has been
quite unpleasant to say the least and
for them never knowing their granddad
apart from the some grainy pictures I
mean he guard them from from the bars of
what went on but you know they must know
about the campaigner must be they must
be proud of me too whether they whether
left proud but I am you know like you
say I have protected them from it
because that you know they're still only
so small and but my eldest son is 13 and
he knows you know he knows and he's
always dad why did they open the gate
and why did they say they didn't when
they did and you know you try and give
them answers as best as you can because
they are so innocent and but at the same
time you know you have to be honest yes
he's quite right to keep asking this
question yeah it wasn't people are you
keeping asking those questions we
wouldn't have been here I think we're
all proud of you more proud
you know as as you've just said I was
only six and so I've only joined the
campaign you know in sort of like the
last ten years when I was old enough to
do so and so I need to be I'll be
forever indebted to the family members
that fought when I was so young to do so
because if it wasn't for them for
standing up when I was just a child I
wouldn't be here standing next to them
today and I owe that to them
yeah they pass the torch on to you but
you're keeping it Bernie Charlotte thank
you very much indeed Wayne Dadhichi
really really good talking to you thank
you very much indeed